[Musik]
[Applaus]
jörg erwacht aus einem langen schlaf
überall in der stadt wird das leben
zurück und wir wollen wissen was
passiert in dieser welt metropole eine
inzidenz von um die 500 über monate war
new york eine geisterstadt war der tod
allgegenwärtig hatten hunderttausende
ihren job verloren
auch er zehn jahre war ein griff ins
kino an der new yorker metropolitan
opera
dann war vor einem jahr auf einen schlag
schluss heute singe ich nur noch unter
der dusche oder bad die dusche vergibt 4
schon als kind wollte ein opernsänger
werden auf der ganz großen bühne
es war sein großer traum der aber
zerplatzt an einem virus dass das leben
in der stadt zum erliegen bringt rein
aber gibt nicht auf das kann man sich in
dieser stadt nicht leisten ich habe aus
meiner verzweiflung heraus das bedürfnis
gespürt etwas zu finden auf das ich mich
in der zukunft verlassen kann
um dieses gefühl nie wieder haben zu
müssen ohne arbeit zu sein in einer
industrie die komplett verschwindet
und so schult er um auf krankenpflege
ein krisensicherer job sagt er das habe
diese pandemie gezeigt weil new york
aber durch krankenpflege alleine nicht
überleben kann hat der gouverneur schon
anfang des jahres den plan für die
rückkehr zum normalen leben ausgegeben
wir können es uns schlicht nicht leisten
die stadt geschlossen zu halten bis wir
genügend impfstoff haben
der preis wäre zu hoch wir hätten dann
nichts mehr was wir öffnen könnten
wir müssen die wirtschaft öffnen aber
wir müssen das smart und sicher tun
die inzidenz spielt bei diesem plan
anders als in deutschland praktisch
keine rolle viel wichtiger ist die
entwicklung bei den schweren verläufen
und auslastung der intensivbetten und
die zahl der todesfälle
alle drei faktoren sind seit anfang
februar rückläufig unter auflagen können
kinos und museen wieder öffnen
restaurants können drinnen und draußen
bis zu 50 prozent belegt werden
auch in geschäften einkaufen oder zum
friseur gehen in new york city
kein problem
es war schlimm aber es wird langsam
besser
wir werden eine glänzende zukunft haben
wir sind noch nicht wieder auf vor
pandemie level aber werden da hinkommen
den sommer rutsche wir denken über leben
es ist noch nicht wie vor der pandemie
vor einem jahr
aber wir können über lehren new yorks
eröffnungs strategie basiert auf drei
säulen basis das maske tragen praktisch
alle tun es immer und überall auch
draußen auf der straße
und dann ist da das testen vergangenen
sommer schon können sich new yorker
bequem so oft und wann sie wollen testen
lassen
ärzten im test zentren oder wie hier
einfach auf der straße mobilen
einrichtungen
ich habe mich schon 19 mal testen lassen
das ist super ich bin negativ es ist
umsonst
das ist großartig ich bin zwar schon
ernst aber ich lasse mich trotzdem
testen so handelt man verantworten
getestet wird mit dem teuren pcr
verfahren die antigen schnell das machen
wir nicht sie sind viel zu ungenau zu
viel falsch positiv und negativ das
schadet mehr als dass es hilft das
ergebnis hier gibt es innerhalb von 24
stunden
und dann ist da der impfstoff seit
wochen rollt der nachschub oft rund um
die uhr wird geimpft
sieben tage die woche in apotheken bei
ärzten oder riesigen impfzentren und
auch die verkehrsbetriebe haben sich
etwas besonderes einfallen lassen
das hier ist ein paar plan weil man hier
auf das spritzen symbol drückt krupps
kann man sehen wo man sich überall
impfen lassen kann in der ganzen stadt
das ist schon sehr beeindruckend
die app zeigt auch gleich an welcher
impfstoff gespritzt wird und ob man im
berechtigt ist wenn ja kann man gleich
online einen termin vereinbaren
es wird geklotzt und nicht gekleckert
gestern überrascht der bürgermeister
dann mit einer ankündigung mit denen
niemand so schnell gerechnet hatte new
yorker ab 30 können jetzt impftermine
bekommen und nächste woche am sechsten
april sind dann alle über 16 berechtigt
wir sind bereit
es ist vor allem das rasante impft tempo
dass das leben auf die straßen new yorks
zurückkehren ist überall in der stadt
unangekündigte pop up konzert finanziert
von stadt und bundesstaat um die kultur
am leben zu erhalten
das bedeutet eine menge ich fühle mich
privilegiert zu den ersten zu gehören
die wieder draußen auftreten kann
vor einem live-publikum und nicht in
einem livestream mit der öffnung der
theater und konzerthäuser aber wird es
noch ein bisschen da vor eingriffen ist
das okay besser warten bis es sicher ist
als alles wieder zu machen so lange wie
der tenor und krankenpfleger erstmal
weiter singen zu hause
in seinem badezimmer